Hi, welcome to the Anti-National Show. I'm Ashley, and we're here to talk to you today
about our 15-day cleanse. But before we get started, please hit the like, subscribe,
and the little little button on your screen so you don't miss an episode. So this 15-day
cleanse that we're going to be talking about is a scientifically-based, so that's one thing
that really drew us to it, was the research behind it. Yes, so first of all, why do we
do a metabolic cleanse or what's the big deal about it? So basically it all comes down to living
in a toxic world and what we're exposed to, and it's kind of that balance between toxins coming
in, your body being able to get rid of the toxins. So you always want to be getting rid of toxins
more than you are being exposed to toxins. So, you know, we're exposed in the air that we breathe,
the water that we drink, the foods that enter our body, you know, our foods are, we're not getting
proper nutrition, we're under chronic stress. We don't sleep well in all of these things,
EMF exposures. That's just to name a few, all of these things add up and they create what's called
oxidative stress within our body. And when we have oxidative stress, it eventually can lead to multiple
organ systems becoming compromised or diseased. This can lead to symptoms such as, you know, maybe just a
skin rash, maybe some fatigue, maybe, you know, sleep issues, mood issues, so a lot of symptoms.
And the other thing that we really like about this cleanse is that there is a symptom survey that you
take before you start this. So you can see where you're at and all of these different symptoms,
symptom categories. And then at the end of it, you retake that same test and you see where you have
improved. Obviously the goal is to get rid of the toxins, but in that you're reducing symptoms and
you just feel better overall. You are better, you're healthier, you're nourishing everybody. And
other things we like about the cleanse is it's only 15 days. So it is super doable. Yeah, it's
doable. It's a cleanse that is scientifically researched to help your body revitalize its ability
to detox, which is huge. It also can help us with reducing inflammation, help your digestive
health. It can also help heal the gut and then get your body to its optimal function, which is going
to help decrease those symptoms on your symptom survey. And then it also can utilize the macro
nutrients and the micro nutrients as well, which are actually required for all phases of detoxification
that are vital needs. It can also be super easy when it's all laid out for you. And that's
one thing this one does is it's easy to follow. It gives you a plan of action and it tastes delicious.
Yes. That's always a bonus. Yes. So what is included, you're going to get 30 shake packets. So you're
going to do two shakes per day. And then there's also 30 supplement packets. So two packets of
supplements per day, you get a shaker bottle, the mix up your shakes, you get the complete guide book
that outlines and details the program. It gives you the yeses and noes on the food. So it gives you dietary
recommendations. It's going to give you sample menus, ideas of what to eat for breakfast or for lunch,
snacks, dinner. Typically with this one, you're going to have some snacks on that one meal a day.
That is if you're interested in losing some weight, if you don't want to lose weight, then you would
do either two meals a day in snacks or you can stretch it out to a 30-day cleanse and just do one of the
shake packets and one of the supplement packets per day. That's if you don't want to lose weight.
Yes. So the protein powder that's included in there, the shakes you'll be drinking will be vegan, non-GMO
certified organic, pea protein. It has some enzymes in there as well. And then it also takes your
micro nutrients to convert the fats and carbohydrates into energy. So that's a huge
component of that as well. Right. And then in addition to kind of the protein component of it,
in the blend of fibers and all those other things, there's a nitro grains component. So this is
taking it's an alkalizing formula that feeds the nitric oxide pathways. So again, it's coming from
100% organic, whole foods, extracts, and concentrates that are automatically active with a
high anti-oxidant value and a rich chlorophyll content. And so this supports healthy immune system
and obviously healthy detoxification. Yes. Then we have the capsules. So the other package
contains five capsules, which is going to support the bile production and the liver health,
which are both essential for all phases of detoxification as well, the blend that it's in. And it
also binds to the toxins and helps it you eliminate them quickly, but safely so you're not
reabsorbing them. The bile production and the liver support is key when you go through all of those
detoxification phases for a successful cleanse. So to kind of bring this all together and recap,
the name of the product is the Nutric Clear Plus 15-day metabolic cleanse. Again, it's to support
the detoxification pathways. It's to give your body anti-oxidant support with the micronutrients.
It is to nourish the liver and the gallbladder so you can produce healthy bile, which is important
for detoxification and miniminations, because you digestive support. It's eliminating all of the foods
that can cause an immune response or allergic reaction. So that's important to just quiet the immune
system, let your body heal. Let your gut heal. So it's no ingredients that are going to disrupt the
barrier. The gut that's going to be gut healing, which is really important as well. And again, to support
a healthy inflammatory response for healing, right? So what you gain is better sleep, more energy,
maybe a better mood, depending on what your symptom survey said. And of course, the bonuses weight
loss. Again, some people aren't trying to lose weight, so they'll extend it to the 30-day with any type
of toxin pull in your fat cells. So intercellular detoxification, there is going to be some weight loss.
So just keep that in mind as well. But some people had some goals. So yeah, it is a bonus.
And we are going to start this clinic. We are going to start November 13th, which will bring us
to the day before Thanksgiving. And we're really excited. Yeah. And we cannot wait. We want to
just start it today, after eating really junky this weekend. Yeah, we have some birthday parties going on.
There's cake involved. I did not have that excuse. But yes, exactly. So we're really excited about
it. If you've been thinking about doing a cleanse or a detox or want to get on some type of protocol to
jumpstart your health, this would be a great option. Yes, really a great option. And if you purchase
the metabolic cleanse, we're going to give you a call for free shipping, valid through the month of
November. So the code that you would punch in during checkout is show. And join us. And we will be
there to support you. Again, if you purchase the cleanse, we will send you a like to take that symptom
survey. And it creates a really neat report that kind of puts you at a category of the toxicity.
So you can kind of read up about it. But the interesting thing is, too, you get to see where your
symptoms are. And then again, when you take it, it tracks where your symptoms are after. And so you
get this visual of how you've improved. So yes, it's super neat. That's one thing that we were super
drawn to. Right. And we have tasted it because we went to a seminar on this. We did taste it. And it
tasted really good. The shapes are good. You can mix it with almond milk or dairy free milk of your choice.
Yes. Well, I hope this was helpful for you. And this cleanse is something that maybe you're
interested in. Reach out to us if you have any questions. Again, your first nutritional consultation
is always free. You can find that and all the information we've discussed on the links below this
video. Again, hit the like and subscribe button and the alert button so you don't miss an
episode. And we'll see you next time. See you next time.